sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren zunächst muss ich ihnen
natürlich eine falsche hoffnung nehmen
es ist nicht meine letzte rede als
fraktionsvorsitzender im bundestag sie
müssen mich schon noch mal ertragen
das wollte ich ihnen nur vorher schon
sagen ja damit sie nicht bald strahlen
aber kommen wir mal zu der frage wie
heute die welt aussieht
ich glaube die situation ist sehr ernst
wir stehen vor gewaltigen problemen
kriege und kriegsähnliche
auseinandersetzungen finden in syrien im
jemen im irak in der türkei in der
ukraine und in anderen ländern statt
kriege töten vernichten und zerstören
und die menschen fliehen um nicht
getötet nicht vernichtet zu werden
wie sehen die staaten aus in denen auch
der westen krieg geführt hat afghanistan
eine einzige katastrophe
armut und demokratische verhältnisse
terroristische selbstmordanschläge und
zunehmend flüchtlingen alle anderen
fraktionen waren für den krieg in
afghanistan
nur die linke war dagegen und hat vor
den folgen gewarnt
sie können es drehen und wenden wie sie
wollen
wir hatten recht glücklicherweise hat
sich deutschland nicht unmittelbar an
den kriegen gegen den irak und gegen
libyen beteiligt aber die usa
großbritannien frankreich und andere
länder wo sie ihn war schlimm und es weg
aber ist die situation jetzt besser
gaddafi war schlimm und es weg aber ist
die situation jetzt besser krieg muss
überwunden werden wenn man ernsthaft
will dass menschen diesbezüglich nicht
gezwungen werden zu fliegen
deutschland ist aber der drittgrößte
waffenexporteur der welt verdient an
jedem krieg waffen werden auch an
diktaturen wie saudi-arabien und katar
verkauft
saudi arabien führt einen krieg gegen
nehmen wird sie dennoch waffen aus
deutschland
diese unheilvolle politik muss
überwunden werden
verhindern sie doch wenigstens
waffenverkäufe an diktaturen und in
krisengebiete das ist doch nur ein
minimum und wenigstens und wenigstens
die sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands müsste darauf bestehen wir
erleben darüber hinaus eine
entstaatlichung von statten wir haben
zunehmend länder in denen regierung
polizei justiz bildung und
gesundheitswesen nicht funktionieren oft
ist es die folge der vom westen
geführten kriege wenn es keine
funktionierenden regierungen gibt gibt
es auch keine verhandlungspartner die
etwas durchsetzen können die bürgerinnen
und bürger können so nicht geschützt
werden ein staatliches staaten syrien
libyen irak jemen somalia für den ersten
vier ländern sind inzwischen 9000
schulen geschlossen worden
lehrerinnen und lehrer fliegen und auch
die eltern mit ihren kindern fliehen
weil diese ohne schulbildung chancenlos
in ihrem leben wären was tut die
bundesregierung dagegen
ich bin gespannt auf ihre antwort frau
bundeskanzlerin und warum erfahren wir
eigentlich so wenig in den medien über
die mörderischen auseinandersetzung in
diesen ländern ich finde dass
information wichtig ist ich wiederhole
mich
jährlich sterben auf der erde etwa 70
millionen menschen die häufigste
todesursache ist der hunger jährlich
sterben etwa 18 millionen menschen auf
der erde an hunger
wir haben aber weltweit eine
landwirtschaft die die menschheit
zweimal ernähren könnte menschen die
angst haben zu verhungern fliegen was
tut die bundesregierung dagegen dass der
profit von konzerne vorrang vor dem
verhungern von menschen hat auch darauf
frau bundeskanzlerin müssten sie eine
antwort geben
not elend also armut nehmen weltweit
ebenso zu wie auch der reichtum an
wächst nur ganz wenige zahlen
seit 2008 hat sich die zahl der
milliardäre auf der erde verdoppelt die
reichsten 80 personen auf der erde
besitzen genauso viel wie die ärmere
hälfte der menschheit das heißt wie 35
milliarden menschen 80 menschen besitzen
genauso viel wie 35 milliarden menschen
interessant ist vor fünf jahren besaß
diese hälfte 588 388 personen und
interessantes aus 388 personen werden
nicht 400 500 und 1 600 sondern daraus
werden
80 weil der reichtum sich ganz anders
konzentriert eine milliarde menschen
haben ein einkommen von einem dollar pro
tag
armut bittere armut führt ebenso zur
flucht dagegen unternimmt die
bundesregierung nichts denn auf
wesentlich höherem niveau passiert in
europa und deutschland das gleiche
die oecd stellt ihr jetzt fast fest dass
die kluft zwischen arm und reich in
deutschland sich deutlich vergrößert hat
übrigens immer mit einer spd in der
regierung
ich kann es doch nicht ändern sie müssen
endlich einfach an die reichsten zehn
prozent der bevölkerung verdiente mitte
der achtzigerjahre fünfmal so viel wie
die ärmsten zehn prozent unserer
bevölkerung inzwischen verdienen sie
sieben mal so viel
ein prozent der bevölkerung in
deutschland besitzt 32 prozent des
gesamten vermögens und die finanziell
schwächere hälfte der haushalte also 50
prozent unserer haushalte besitzt ein
prozent des vermögens 50 prozent
besitzen ein prozent des vermögens und
das interessante ist 1998 besaß diese
hälfte noch vier prozent des vermögens
und aus vier prozent werden ihm nicht 5
und dann 6 und 1 7 prozent sondern aus
vier prozent wird ein prozent das ist
eine katastrophe damit machen sie die
gesellschaft kaputt
und ein staat der selbst so ungerecht
verteilt kann sich auch nicht weltweit
wirksam gegen armut einsetzen und
organisiert mithin schon wieder
flüchtlinge nachgewiesen wird von der
oecd übrigens auch wie schädlich für die
binnenwirtschaft die schwächung der
kaufkraft eines großen teils unserer
bevölkerung ist der generalsekretär der
oecd sagte zitiere wörtlich der kampf
gegen ungleichheit muss in das zentrum
der politischen debatte rücken
die linke wird genau das versuchen
weltweit muss auch ein geschiedener
kampf gegen rassismus geführt werden
sinti und roma sind zum beispiel die in
vielen europäischen ländern erheblich
benachteiligten teile der bevölkerung
sie fliehen in der hoffnung endlich
irgendwo hinzukommen wo sie
gleichberechtigt behandelt werden gerade
in diesen viel diskutierten westlichen
balkanländern findet eine
menschenrechtsverletzung und
menschenrechtsverachtenden politik
gegenüber sinti und roma statt außerdem
ist die politik von oben in ungarn
schlicht indiskutabel und dagegen muss
ganzen stellen
wenn die bundesregierung nicht ernsthaft
beginnen die fluchtursachen wirksam zu
bekämpfen
die weltprobleme ernsthaft anzugehen
werden sie täglich verschärfter zu uns
kommen bis sie unbeherrschbar sind
natürlich frau bundeskanzlerin
können sie das nicht allein das erwartet
auch niemand aber was bereden sie
eigentlich auf den g7 g8 oder g20 gipfel
warum drängen sie nicht darauf wirksam
gegen krieg hunger not elend armut und
rassismus vorzugehen
das wäre doch wohl das mindeste nun
erwarten wir in diesem jahr 800 1000
flüchtlinge in deutschland die
eigentlich kein problem sondern eine
chance
ich begrüße es ausdrücklich vor
bundeskanzlerin dass sie für flüchtlinge
unhcr hier die türen geöffnet haben aber
ich sage auch die zustände ungarn müssen
ganz deutlich verändert werden dazu
komme ich noch also es ist eigentlich
fantastisch dass viele tausende menschen
zu uns kommen aber es ist noch
fantastischer wie viele tausende
menschen sie begrüßen ehrenamtlich aktiv
sind sie unterstützen ich glaube das
hätte es so vor zehn jahren noch nicht
gegeben
das ist erst mal eine sehr gute
entwicklung aber auf der anderen seite
darf man das auch nicht überziehen auch
ehrenamtliche helfer sind irgendwann
müde sind irgendwann abgespannt das
heißt der bund muss eingreifen und vor
allen dingen die strukturellen probleme
lösen
auf der anderen seite haben wir ein
rechtsextremer der rassistischen hass
und flüchtlingsunterkünfte in brand
setzte und ich sage ihnen dagegen müssen
wir geschlossen auftreten egal wie groß
ansonsten unsere meinungsunterschiede
sind aber es gibt auch menschen die
ängste damit verbinden die glauben dass
es ihnen besser ginge wenn es weniger
flüchtlinge gebe ich habe sie gefragt ob
es ihnen denn besser ging bevor die
flüchtlinge kam das muss sie verneinten
das ist überhaupt kein logisches
argument aber wir sind trotzdem
verpflichtet diese abstrakten ängste
abzubauen und wir sind verpflichtet mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit herzustellen
denn ich sage ihnen wenn verhältnisse so
sozial ungerecht sind dann nutzt dass
der rechtsextremismus aus um leute für
sich zu gewinnen mit schlichten
rassistischen und anderen lösungen also
machen wir das nicht nur aus materiellen
gründen sondern auch aus wichtigen
ideellen gründen dass wir kämpfen für
deutlich mehr soziale gerechtigkeit in
deutschland den übrigen der ärmeren teil
der bevölkerung
es gärt teil der immer seltener zur wahl
geht das ist demokratie gefährden
wir müssen also auch mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit gestalten damit sie wieder
die demokratie begrüßen und sich an
wahlen beteiligen
die flüchtlinge sind ja schon deshalb
eine chance bei uns immer mehr
arbeitskräfte fehlen
der arbeitgeberpräsident begrüßt deshalb
den zustrom an flüchtlingen
jedes jahr sterben bekanntlich mehr
deutsche als geboren werden
das handwerklich nicht verlernt worden
ist müssen wir uns noch mal gedanken
darüber machen woran das liegt und ich
sage ihnen
das liegt daran dass wir keine
kinderfreundliche gesellschaft sind es
liegt daran dass wir ein bildungssystem
aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert haben
dass es kein chancengleichen zugang zur
bildung zu kunst und kultur bei kindern
gibt davon kann nicht einmal im ansatz
die rede sein und die umfassende prekäre
beschäftigung dank agenda 2010
verhindert dass die menschen
verantwortungsbewusst kinder in die welt
setzen können massenhaft kriegen junge
leute nur befristete verträge sie von
einigen monaten sie wissen nicht mal was
aus ihnen wird geschweige denn was aus
ihren kindern werden soll
all das sind die ursachen dafür aber
selbst wenn wir das muss ich so deutlich
sagen aber selbst wenn wir flüchtlinge
wirtschaftlich nicht brauchten sind wir
verpflichtet sie anständig zu behandeln
anständig unterzubringen und zu
integrieren
deshalb ist es gut frau bundeskanzlerin
dass sie im kommenden jahr sechs
milliarden euro im bundeshaushalt dafür
einsetzen wollen
es ist ein schritt in die richtung
richtige richtung aber das geld genügt
ich und vor allem ist es keine
strukturelle lösung
deshalb sage ich ihnen noch einmal wir
müssten den solidaritätszuschlag eben
nicht abschaffen sondern beibehalten und
gerecht unter den 16 bundesländern
verteilen damit sie die aufgaben bei der
unterbringung bei der integration der
flüchtlinge meistern können übrigens ist
das asylverfahren bundesrecht und
insofern müssen meines erachtens müssen
die kosten auch beim bund getragen
werden und nicht von den ländern und
kommunen
es ist richtig dass sie mehr
deutschkurse anbieten aber ihre
überlegungen flüchtlinge schneller
loszuwerden gehen eindeutig in die
falsche richtung
sie erweitern die sicheren
herkunftsländern gerkens länder um
schneller abschieben zu können
so soll jetzt ein sicheres herkunftsland
der kosovo sein wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe sie begründen uns doch
immer die notwendigkeit der bundeswehr
im kosovo weil es dort so unsicher ist
was stimmt denn nun braucht man dort die
bundeswehr oder ist das ein sicheres
land also sie müssen hier auch mal eine
logik in ihre politik bringen und
übrigens der vorschlag bargeld für
flüchtlinge abzuschaffen und durch
gutscheine zu ersetzen widerspricht
schon jetzt eine entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gehen sie doch
keinen grundgesetzwidrigen weg er ist
immer falsch
flüchtlinge sollen nach drei monaten
leiharbeit verrichten dürfen sie wollen
also einen neuen sektor für niedriglohn
eröffnen auch dass es indiskutabel
darunter sind übrigens oft viele
qualifizierte kräfte dann wird mir immer
gesagt ja ob die qualifikation stimmt
oder nicht mein gott wir haben noch
immer eine probezeit da weiß ein arzt
sofort ob das stimmt oder ob das nicht
stimmt hier müssen wir mal etwas
lockerer etwas unbürokratischer werden
und dafür sorgen dass die menschen so
schnell wie möglich beschäftigung finden
sechs osteuropäische länder erklärten
als mit flüchtlings quoten einverstanden
zu sein tschechien slowakei polen ungarn
litauen und lettland
nun bin ich auch gegen quoten weil es
sich nämlich um menschen handelt und
nicht um sachen und die kann man nicht
einfach verteilen aber eine gerechte
kostenverteilung innerhalb der
europäischen union halte ich für
zwingend erforderlich
und wenn dann länder die kaum
flüchtlinge aufnehmen nicht bereit sind
ihren kostenanteil zuzahlen müssen ihnen
die zuschüsse aus der eu entsprechend
gekürzt werden da muss man jetzt mal
mehr mit teuren das ganze übrigens
erklärt er die polnische regierung dass
polen für muslimische gläubige
flüchtlinge so ungeeignet sein
nur ist dieses land doch bekanntlich
schwer katholisch geprägt es kann doch
nicht wahr sein dass ich den jetzt schon
wieder die bergpredigt von jesus
christus erklären muss und wenn diese
mitglieder der polnischen regierung zur
beichte gehen müssen die so viel
rosenkränze bieten das sie gar nicht
mehr rauskommen aus der kirche ich kann
nur sagen führen sie mit denen mal die
auseinandersetzung scharf und deutlich
ungarn mannschaft schritt für schritt
die demokratie ab strebt eindeutig
autoritäre strukturen an
das verkündet er sogar die usa haben
bereits sanktionen ausgesprochen
und was macht unsere bundesregierung sie
malt etwas vor sich hin dass rechtlich
hier müssen wirklich maßnahmen ergriffen
werden
aber auch dies nicht nur durch die
bundesregierung
und noch was das interessiert mich frau
merkel herr kauder und frau hasselfeldt
also orbáns partei ist mitglied der
konservativen fraktion im europäischen
parlament
das heißt die abgeordneten der cdu und
der csu sitzenden einer fraktion mit den
mitgliedern
von orbáns partei meinen sie nicht es
wird höchste zeit diese partei aus ihrer
europäischen fraktion rauszuschmeißen
und 28
insgesamt sieht man die unzureichenden
strukturen der eu nichts wirksames
geschieht gegen hoffmanns unerträgliche
politik russland russland ist eine
weltmacht und nicht wie obama meinte
eine regionalmacht russland ist eine
veto macht es ist das militärisch
stärkste land in europa obama verlangte
wirtschaftssanktionen durch die eu auch
durch die bundesrepublik wie immer bei
der us-minister ration sind sie artig
gefolgt haben alles gemacht was sie
wollten
wir haben dadurch deutliche wirtschafts
einbußen ich kenne mittelständische
unternehmen die geliefert hatten an
russland die jetzt gar nicht mehr wissen
wie sie noch die insolvenz verhindern
soll und nun lese ich das nach
russischen angaben der handel zwischen
den usa und russland um sechs bis elf
prozent zugenommen hat am ende das wäre
doch eine sagenhafte frechheit von uns
aktion zu verlangen und selbst den
handel zu steigern
und deshalb sage ich ihnen hören sie
endlich auf sie müssen eine
eigenständige interessenpolitik machen
es gibt keinen frieden in europa ohne
oder gegen russland das müssen wir
beachten es übrigens noch was
er zögere ich plötzlich dass russland
waffen und gruppen um syrien zusammen
zieht dann lese ich das sei alles
abgestimmt mit den usa
dann lese ich wiederum dass die
us-regierung die russische regierung
warnt jetzt frage ich mich ist die
warnung auch abgestimmt das heißt sagt
man macht das mal aber wir müssen so tun
als ob wir dagegen sind
ich hoffe frau bundeskanzlerin sie
können das einfach aufklären und sagen
wie es da wirklich aussehen es wird zeit
dass unsere bevölkerung diesbezüglich
informiert wird und noch was ich
verstehe sehr gut dass man
hat nicht mehr verletzt menschenrechte
in vielfacher hinsicht
das kann ich alles nachvollziehen aber
man wird doch wirklich einen frieden
ohne assad nicht finden ist die
friedensfrage nicht wichtiger als die
frage wie man aus menschenrechtsgründen
ablehnt oder nicht ablehnt letztlich
müssen wir begreifen und danach handeln
frieden und sicherheit brauchen wir
überall auf der erde und nicht darf
deutschland der drittgrößte
waffenexporteur der welt sein volk ein
es gab einen friedensprozess zwischen
der regierung der türkei und den vögeln
und kursen dann hat sich die regierung
entschieden krieg zu führen gegen die
pkk jetzt sagt erdogan es gibt für ihn
nur noch eine militärische lösung er
marschiert sogar in den irak ein
aber gerade sie syrischen und iranischen
kurdinnen und kurden wenn ich darauf
hinweisen will führen den einzig
wirklich wirksamen kampf am boden gegen
den islamischen stadt und die werden
jetzt bekriegt und zwar von einem nato
partner
und was machen sie dagegen nicht geben
sie doch mal diese schweigen auf und
suchen sie die wirkliche
auseinandersetzung mit erdogan
weil das nicht mehr hinnehmbar
griechenland herr schäuble
vielleicht haben sie ihr ziel erreicht
und die linke regierung ist gestürzt
wir warten das ergebnis der wahl aber
eins hat die linke regierung erreicht
aus griechenland eine diskussion in ganz
europa über den euro und über die eu
strukturen wie wir sie noch nie hatten
jetzt steht die frage eu weiter in
richtung demokratie und sozialabbau oder
endlich umgekehrt in richtung mehr
demokratie und mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit zu gestalten
wir brauchen die eu für den frieden in
europa aber eben auch für mehr
demokratie und soziale gerechtigkeit
und ich sage ihnen herr schäuble wir
haben leider mit ihrer politik und sie
natürlich auch frau bundeskanzlerin
erreicht dass der rechtspopulismus und
der rechtsextremismus der zurück will
zu den alten nationalstaaten erfolge
zeigt in den europäischen ländern schon
das müsste sie wachrütteln und die
politik gänzlich ändern
tcp ip also wir haben ja immer
kritisiert bei dem sogenannten
freihandelsabkommen das da verhandelt
wird zwischen den usa und der
europäischen union die mangelnde
transparenz ist hat sich ein kleines
bisschen verbessert aber nicht viel und
jetzt nenne ich ihnen nur drei probleme
erstens wir kennen ein vorsorgeprinzip
das in den usa unbekanntes die canon 1
nachsorge prinzip das heißt wenn du in
deutschland ein neues lebensmittel auf
den markt bringen willst musst du
beweisen dass das nicht schädlich ist
dass wir da manchmal falsch überweise
kriegen es eine ganz andere frage
aber man muss es beweisen in den usa ist
es genau umgekehrt
da kannst du jedes mit lebensmittel auf
den markt bringt nur wenn du dann
schaden anrichtet wenn man zum 2
milliarden beurteilt das aber eine
völlig umgekehrt herangehensweise und da
sagen mir die mittelständischen
unternehmen
sie liegen damit um zwei bis drei jahre
zurück und haben einen ganz großen
nachteil
das sollte sie doch eigentlich
interessieren das zweite sind die
schiedsgerichte
die schiedsgerichte sind doch
abenteuerlich sie müssen sich mal
überlegen
da kommt ein kanadischer oder
amerikanischer konzern klagt vor einem
schiedsgericht und bekommt dann 200
milliarden euro schadenersatz durch die
bundesregierung zugebilligt und sie
können nichts mehr machen es gibt kein
weiteres gericht werde ein deutsches
noch ein europäisches und die eigenen
unternehmen die müssen bis zum
europäischen gerichtshof gehen oder bis
zum bundesverfassungsgericht um
irgendetwas durchzusetzen wiederum eine
schwere benachteiligung
ich weiß dass die wirtschaft für ein
freihandelsabkommen ist wir sagen dazu
nein aber ich weiß auch welche kritik
sie daran üben und die sollten sie ernst
nehmen und jetzt kommt das dritte das
für unsere mix entscheidende kriterium
das ist das verbot und
investitionshemmnissen ich bitte sie
wissen sie was das heißt
das heißt folgendes also ein
amerikanischer konzern gründet seinen
sitz in deutschland zurück einem
zeitpunkt da gibt es eine bestimmte
rechtliche situation jetzt haben wir
neuwahlen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland und sagen wir mal es
entstehen eine vernünftige regierung
also aus oder mit linken und jetzt jetzt
erlauben die sich ja man darf das
träumen gestern nicht verboten und was
sind auf jetzt erlauben die sich jetzt
erlauben die sich die mitbestimmung in
unternehmen zu erweitern vielleicht
sogar ein kleines bisschen die steuern
für die konzerne zu erhöhen und dann
sagen die das verstößt gegen das verbot
von investitionshemmnissen wenn sie das
unterschreiben wenn sie das
unterschreiben dann sagen sie dass eine
politik in einer bestimmten richtung
verboten ist und nur noch reaktionärer
die verhältnisse werden dürfen da kann
doch die sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands in anbetracht ihrer
geschichte eigentlich niemals zu schlimm
aber sie organisieren das ganze
komme ich zur prekären beschäftigung wir
haben in deutschland nach wie vor den
größten niedriglohnsektor in europa wir
hatten mal vor 20 jahren 26 millionen
menschen in vollzeit jetzt nur noch 22
millionen
der anteil an prekärer beschäftigung das
heißt als 100 teilzeit befristung
leiharbeit geringfügiger beschäftigung
ist von ist um 70 prozent gestiegen und
beträgt jetzt 21 prozent aller
beschäftigten
ich sage ihnen ganz klar leiharbeit ist
für mich eine moderne form der sklaverei
und muss verboten werden
aber wenn zwischen ausnahme machen dann
müssten sie wenigstens dafür sorgen dass
eine leiharbeiterin und ein leiharbeiter
ab erster stunde beschäftigung anspruch
auf 110 prozent des lohnes hat den
anderer beschäftigter in dem unternehmen
für die gleiche tätigkeit bezieht damit
es endlich zur ausnahme wird und nicht
zu einem nötigungs mittel um die eigene
belegschaft das weihnachtsgeld das
urlaubsgeld und vieles andere zu
entziehen und mit press tung darf es
wohl noch mit sachgrund geben und nicht
willkürlich wie heute und auch die
erzwungene zeit hat teilzeit müssen wir
loswerden wenn dann freiwillig aber mit
dem recht auf rückkehr zur
vollbeschäftigung
übrigens die frauen trifft es besonders
hart die vollzeit quote bei frauen sank
von 55 auf 40 prozent und die teils hält
jobs für frauen nahmen zu von 3,8 auf 63
millionen ich sage ihnen armut ist immer
weiblich deshalb war der streik der
erzieherinnen und erzieher und der
sozialarbeiterinnen und sozialarbeiter
so wichtig um wenigstens zu erreichen
dass endlich diese klassischen
frauenberufe nicht so grottenschlecht
bezahlt werden wie das gegenwärtig der
fall ist wir brauchen gleiche
gleichwertige arbeit übrigens frau
nahles
wenn auch aus unserer sicht völlig
unzureichend aber ihre gesetze zur
begrenzung von leiharbeit gegen den
missbrauch von werkverträgen man setzt
du dir eigentlich mal und es wird ja
zeit das kann man doch nicht bloß
beschließen also ich sage ihnen ganz
klar wir werden einen entschiedenen
kampf gegen die prekäre beschäftigung
und den niedriglohnsektor in deutschland
für ich komme zum schluss und sage ihnen
folgendes leicht wusste ich will ihnen
doch zwischendurch auch mal eine kleine
freude machen also wenn wir jetzt über
die halbzeit der großen koalition reden
dann darf ich doch drei dinge bewerten
erstens immer wieder wird behauptet dass
sie frau merkel die cdu
sozialdemokratisierte welches bild muss
inzwischen eigentlich von
sozialdemokratie herrschen wenn ihre
politik als sozialdemokrat schritt aber
ich frage mich welche projekte sie
eigentlich in den nächsten zwei jahren
anfangen wollen leider glaube ich nicht
dass sie wirksam die fluchtursachen
bekämpfen
die rüstungsexporte wesentlich und
deutlich beschränken
ein kampf führen gegen den
niedriglohnsektor und die prekäre
beschäftigung gegen die altersarmut und
endlich für chancengleichheit
insbesondere für kinder beim zugang zu
bildung kunst und kultur
übrigens auch mit einem deutlich
billigeren öffentlichen nahverkehr
aber was haben sie dann vor erzählen sie
es uns zweitens skizzierte das ist ja
nur ein besonders trauriger fall
wir hatten
wir hatten ja fast ich muss es ihnen
sagen sie hatten aus ihrer sicht zwei
tolle aus meiner sicht zwei ganz
besonders blöde projekte das war erstens
das betreuungsgeld mit dem sie eltern
dafür bezahlten dass sie den lehr dass
sie das lernen ihrer kinder in
kindertagesstätten unterbinden
wir haben ihnen gesagt dass es
grundgesetzwidrig ist
grundgesetzwidrig ist sie haben es uns
nicht geglaubt inzwischen hat es das
bundesverfassungsgericht eindeutig
festgestellt und dann die maut die liebe
csu ich habe ihnen gesagt mit tricks
kann man europa recht nicht umgehen sie
wollten es mir nicht glauben und muss
nun alles stoppen nachdem ein verfahren
gegen unser land in der eu eingeleitet
wurde
ich werde sie inhaltlich nicht
überzeugen können aber glauben sie mir
wenn sie diesbezüglich nicht über solche
mitglieder verfügen müssen sie sich
wenigstens beraterinnen und berater
suchen die sich im europarecht und im
grundgesetz auskennt
drittens ist die spd die spd sitzt auch
wenn sie es gelegentlich vergisst
ebenfalls in der bundesregierung viel zu
spüren ist das allerdings nicht
sie stehen vor einer spannenden frage
wollen sie ein anhängsel der union
bleiben oder doch zu einem gegenüber
werden die depressionen bei ihnen gehen
ja schon so weit dass in ihren reihen
lieber herr gabriel diskutiert wird ob
man überhaupt noch eine eigene
kanzlerkandidatin oder einen eigenen
kanzlerkandidaten aufstellen
mein gott dann kehrt in die
sozialdemokratie endlich mal wieder
leidenschaft kampfgeist und zwar für
frieden und sozialer gerechtigkeit
zurück mein letzter satz
viel hoffnung für die bevölkerung
entsteht durch die übrigens wegen der
grossen mehrheit demokratie gefährden
eine große koalition für die nächsten
beiden jahre nicht aber wer weiß was
2017 passiert